dear president of the european
parliament
the david dear president of the
bundestag liberal of congress dear
presidents of the portuguese and
slovenian parliament
eduardo and igor and of course uh
ladies and gentlemen honorable members
of parliaments
recently the commission secured
the first 300 million doses of a
potential coronavirus vaccine
from the european company biontech
at the same time the story of the
company's co-founder
and ceo made headlines
ugo sahin came to germany
from turkey with his mother when he was
four years old
he passed his high school exam in kern
and went on to study
medicine and today with his wife terezi
the daughter of another immigrant from
turkey
he later founded the german company that
developed a corona virus vaccine
in record time
only shortly after the vaccine
announcement another news broke
sad news this time a ship with
over 120 migrants on board had sunk
right off the coast of libya and
according to reports
74 people died in another incident
spanish rescuers were able to save 110
refugees
refugees in the mediterranean but later
in david you mentioned
it later on board their ship a
six-month-old baby joseph
died well these
two examples highlight just the two
of the aspects we have to think about
when we discuss the issue of migration
on one hand people coming from a
migration background
will contribute to growth innovation and
social dynamism in a country and we
speak to seldom about that and on the
other hand
there are still far too many
heartbreaking stories
of migrants risking their lives on their
way to europe
and both examples make clear why it is
so
important for the european union to
build a system
that manages migration in the long term
and which is fully grounded in european
values
and indeed this is why the european
commission at the end of september
adopted its new pact on migration and
asylum
migration is a complex issue david you
mentioned
all the different pillars and there are
many genuine concerns that have to be
brought into balance
we have to talk about the people seeking
international protection
or a better life exploited by ruthless
smugglers
we have to talk about the concerns of
countries on the eu's external borders
such as italy greece and spain
they worry that the efforts needed to
manage migration may exceed their
capacities
they need the solidarity of others
and of course we have to talk about
those member states that are concerned
that their own national system for
asylum or integration
will not be able to cope in the event
of large amounts of migrants
the current system no longer works
our new pact on migration and asylum
offers a fresh
start the first issue
we are focusing on is a robust and
fair management of external borders
including more efficient and faster
procedures i think this is crucial
so it comprises pre-entry screening
an asylum procedure and of course where
applicable returns
with this procedure simple cases will be
managed much
faster and more effectively than today
at the same time it will guarantee
appropriate
treatment to everybody
the second fundamental element is the
fair sharing of
responsibility on one hand and
solidarity on the other side
those countries that fulfill their legal
and moral
duties or those which are more exposed
than others
must be able to rely on european union
to share responsibility in case of need
and each member state without exception
must support member states under
pressure and they must
ensure that the union meets its
humanitarian obligations
the new system is based on cooperation
and
flexible forms of support so this gives
a choice to member states on
how they contribute but it always
guarantees
that the required support is given and
that
especially at times of pressure on
individual member states
thirdly managing migration well
starts as you've said david in the home
countries of those who come to europe
people do not leave their home easily
and embark on such
a dangerous journey so it's poverty
it's the lack of perspective that are
these strong driving forces
to leave the home country the european
union will therefore
look and work towards tailor-made and
mutual beneficial this is important
partnerships with third countries
these will help to address share
challenges
such as human trafficking and of course
they will help to develop
legal pathways and
they will tackle the effective
implementation of readmission agreements
with our package we also seek to boost
a common eu system for returns
to make eu migration rules more
effective
and credible and lastly
we are also proposing ways to better
benefit from legal migration
into europe people who come to europe
legally
need clear rights and they need to feel
welcomed they need to be given all
necessary opportunities to realize their
potential in our
societies and therefore
next week the commission will present
present
an action plan on integration and
inclusion for
2021-2027
as you know our proposal on the pact was
preceded by extensive consultation with
member states and the european
parliament
you know that vice president marguerite
is and commissioner for home affairs
ilva johansson
traveled from capital to capital to
discuss ideas and proposals and we're in
the parliament
well after this it is clear
and i must say it a solution on
migration that fully satisfies everyone
does not exist we need to come together
on this issue
and we need to discuss and we need to
find compromises
so national parliaments the european
parliament the national governments
we need to acknowledge our differences
and we need to overcome it
but we need to move forward now it
should not get stuck
ladies and gentlemen
in 2015 one of our co-hosts
you wolfgang schwabler spoke of our
european societies having a
rendezvous with globalization
and these words are still true today
indeed migration has always been a
fact for europe and it always will be
it enriches our societies it brings new
talent to our countries
when well managed but if not
and we know that by experience it has
the potential to divide us
so given the urgency of local situations
in several member states there is
no point in fighting the battles of
yesterday
we need a sustainable solution
and we need it now we owe it to the
migrants
we owe it to the refugees and we owe it
to our citizens
many thanks for listening to me and i
look forward to the discussion